欸，你聽過「生命終點服務」平台化跟科技化嗎？我今天看到一個歐洲的創新案例，叫 Solace Care，他們居然在 pre-Seed 輪就募到了 210 萬歐元。
210 萬歐元？這麼敏感又個人化的服務，用平台的方式做，還能拿到這麼多錢，這點我有點懷疑。大家通常不會想把這些事公開吧？
對啊，這就是它讓人詫異的地方。一般人對於臨終規劃或親人過世後的安排，都會覺得是私密且莊重的事情，怎麼會想到用科技平台來處理？
沒錯，我覺得像這種服務，通常大家寧願花更多的錢找專人服務，也不太會信任一個冷冰冰的平台。
但 Solace Care 的做法很有意思。他們的 CEO 說，現在的壽險理賠金付了以後，家屬就得自己處理接下來六個月的所有事情。他們想重新定義個人保險，讓支持不只是一筆錢，而是實際幫助家庭撐下去。
聽起來是想把保險的服務範圍擴大。但具體怎麼做？是不是就把所有需要處理的文件跟流程都數位化，然後放在平台上讓大家自己去點選？
差不多是這個概念，但更全面。他們提供數位平台，讓投保人在生前就能記錄願望、整理文件，留下明確的指示，就像一個數位保險箱。
這個保險箱可以分享給家人，把服務從被保險人延伸到會實際處理這些事務的家人。
嗯，有點像數位遺囑和文件管理系統。這樣家人在遇到變故的時候，就不用手忙腳亂到處找東西，可以減少很多不必要的困擾。
是啊，而且原文有提到，過世之後，Solace Care 還會搭配真人支援，一步步引導家屬處理行政事務，像是機構聯繫等等。這就不是完全的科技化，還是有溫度的。
有真人支援這點就比較能說服我。畢竟有些情感上的支持，機器是沒辦法取代的。但這樣平台化，真的有規模化跟創造商業價值的潛力嗎？
當然有。他們從 2025 年年中開始有第一批投保人，到現在已經涵蓋了瑞典、芬蘭和挪威超過 25,000 條生命。而且 CEO Valtteri Korkiakoski 說，這些成長並不是靠行銷，而是合作夥伴主動把這個方案推薦給客戶後，客戶反應很好。
哇，從零到兩萬五千個投保人，這成長速度是挺快的。所以他們是跟保險公司合作，把這項服務綁在壽險產品裡面賣？
對，就是透過壽險公司和保險經紀人銷售。Solace Care 的共同創辦人 Josef Karakoca 說，一個只有在你過世後才有用的產品，很難賣給一個健康的 35 歲年輕人。
但是如果把規劃和支援整合進去，這份保單就突然變得很有用。這樣對保險公司來說，也是一種加值服務。
我明白了，這其實是把一個「被動等待」的保險商品，變成一個「主動參與」的長期服務。那麼，如果我們是創業者或主管，可以從中學到什麼？
我覺得最大的啟示是，即使是像生命終點這樣高度個人化、看似難以數位化的服務，只要能重新思考服務流程，找出痛點，還是能透過科技找到規模化的解決方案。
嗯，所以就是別太快下定論說某些產業或服務不能平台化，而是要深入去分析需求跟現有痛點。
是的。而且對一般上班族來說，我覺得也可以把這個概念帶入工作。想想看，你手上的工作有沒有哪些流程，雖然看起來很「人情味」或很「客製化」，但其實有機會透過標準化或數位工具，讓它更有效率？
這倒是。也許像我們日常工作中一些需要重複處理的審核流程，或者專案文件的歸檔，雖然涉及人際溝通，但說不定也能找到數位化的切入點。
沒錯。好像也提醒了我們，很多時候我們習慣的做事方式，不見得是唯一的解方。